[Music]
when it comes to Rainbow six siege
eSports we usually talk about the
dynasties
well the dynasty people are always
focused on the top teams and players
that keep winning and crushing their
opponents but the little guys don't
always get the respect that they deserve
nothing is more exciting than a good
cinderella story and that means that
nothing is more exciting than a good
upset so today we wanted to pay respect
to the Cinderella stories to the David's
who managed to dunk on their goliaths
today we're paying respect to the top
ten upsets in Rainbow six siege kicking
off our list is Sonic's eSports is
shocking win to eliminate faze clan at
Dreamhack Montreal 2019 with just one
win in pro league Sonic's were regarded
as the worst team in North America and
anything close to a win would have been
an incredible accomplishment but the
upset was underway now Dom fee and super
half the class on the objective a great
shot there fly on but goddess will take
down a unit the defuser has lost and
she'll grab two for free comfort alone
down the technical 1v2 they want to get
asked her off or that alga pincher the
border Goffe pissing the head on the
repelling super will start to cut them
down with me at the bailiff in
desperation but it's all Neptune's ball
Sonic's 5/3 now we're two rounds away
it's got third number in Neptune's on a
run out now here being stalled and now
it's all down to Astro 20 HP to keep
faceplant alive in Montreal hitting the
air temp super will turn the corner and
that's tough to honest Onix with one of
the biggest upsets on Canadian soil
astonish right
in the world of GGG just takedown phase
then one of the best in a lot of
people's mind no one expected Sonics to
come out on top and their massive upset
over the Brazilian powerhouse could be a
sign of more to come let's hang around a
dreamhack Montreal for a minute because
our number 9 entry comes courtesy of
TSM's impressive and unexpected run at
that very same tournament now TSM
weren't exactly the favourites but their
path to victory was just as impressive
as their meteoric rise with up-and-comer
bolo in the mix throughout the
tournament that North American underdogs
had impressive victories over faze clan
rogue and BDS but it was the grand
finals against Team Liquid where they
proved their worth
and won at all on the troppo chart right
sup sexy cake it's all poly 120 HP in
the main lobby caught out by the yokai
drones it's about to be a three nothing
lead here for TSM is achieved waiting
for any fights to come from up above
would lightning up although the defuse
coming out from sexy cake but it stopped
in its tracks by bolo down to the 2v2 a
chieftain pulling out the control but
Paul with a beautiful shot down to the
1v1 part of dancing around the carnival
with Russian f6 woman back in towards
that diffuser in front of the white van
beautiful shot there from balls he ducks
and darts around that car outside that's
kind of trade though but everyone I
liked with so low HP everyone's wrapping
it up it's all Apollo alone now in the 1
v2 to keep liquid alive as he comes down
your stairs there's no chance North
American you have another champion tree
that you look at every land event
they've attended as they lift the trophy
your
nineteen treemap Montreal champions
taking the number eight spot on our list
is era wealth for their feel-good
victory over Giants gaming against every
odd the quarterfinals match at the
season 10 Pro League finals sought one
of the top European teams take on a
ragtag squad of part-time pros who were
also full-time students trying to avoid
mandatory military service
talk to your au team versus an AIPAC
team with no international success what
could go wrong right rise is making zero
mistake but lunar mental jumps on down
his position give it away by aces 2 for
lunar battle cannot get a thermic ori
swiftly removed from his Sarah as he
does it out to a buck what is going on
right now arrow will take the round have
a lot of manpower o opportunity missed
from hex he could have got one he
doesn't get anything is tara eliminated
Rhys doesn't get a second one
it's all on that bulma and it doesn't
seem likely as he's being flanked right
now the rocks works out and match points
you're gonna have to have the guns come
alive I'll follow finish that's all
thanks middle would be three taking out
these long-standing teams in the region
hex finds one
the giant killers Herald that their
first international land will survive to
the semi-finals sure they lost in the
semis but no one even expected them to
get that far
coming in at number 7 is forces
incredible streak of upsets at the 2019
Rowley major with impressive wins over
vitality and chaos in the qualifiers
these underdogs went on a tear
beating out notable teams like dark zero
and faze clan to top their group come
the quarterfinals the Russian machine
2.0 didn't stop there
taking down Giants in a dominant fashion
but Rask 1 still alive is going to
punish the Giants or that clear of the
top floor he's still up there another
one goes down to Ross can that's three a
triple kill from the top at yellow
well Down Goes Alfama and the Giants
just have nothing now it's all on Hicks
defuser down successfully in forts if
somehow turn this around and ports are
just feasting alive this could be a
tricky spot from the Giants and they're
gonna have to take chances oh but wtg is
there along with comma and it's all Cory
but wtg shuts the door nobody's stopping
them at all fours
Rask will be very important here as he
gets one killin heads back on in
shockwave down so it's essentially a 3v2
but there goes Hicks as well Rask is the
man and rise with a fraction of HP we'll
have to go up against an echo and a full
HP smoke that'll be it we got our first
semifinalists so far here along major
congratulations to the Russian team
Poor's Forza decimated the second ranked
team in the European Pro League and
looked poised to make a Cinderella run
and even though g2 humbled them in the
semi-finals
we'll never forget the run that got them
there number six on our list is mind
freaks inconceivable victory over team
liquid at the 2018 sixth Invitational
despite struggling early on in the group
stage
the Australian underdogs pushed and
found themselves in a best of three
elimination match against the Brazilian
juggernauts they came out swinging and
took the first map but Team Liquid
bounced back with a win of their own to
tie the series going into the third map
Team Liquid started strong but Mindfreak
did not back down and they went all the
way and Manik goes down 8th is the last
defender he gets to only Mets define in
this 1v1 5 seconds to go nest is in the
pressure situation right now he's gonna
take some damage onto the castle this
gets dropped oh no next falls down under
the site and cannot kill the castle a
magnet fells sexy cake as he Sprint's
inside as all the candelas go off there
won't be much out of it as sexy cake had
gone down and magnet gets zig what is
going on with liquids push at the moment
what a shot from magnet and the c4 takes
out uke once again Mindfreak will go
back to match point and only 40 seconds
it's you can zig-zig has lost a lot of
help he will challenge on the mirror
lust he takes him down it's all up to
you he's coming in to push but in the
side of cafeteria sees res res res res
gets it the Aussies do it and a pack
will make it to the quarterfinals what
just happened
my trick just beat Team Liquid the
halfway point on our list is nora rangos
victory over rogue at the pro league
season 8 finals which made them the
first a pack team to make it to semies
at an international event nor Arango
were the clear underdogs
especially since rogue had beaten them
at the season 7 finals but after they
drew rogue for yet another elimination
match nor Arango were out for
user being planted on top of bed means
that denial from below will not be easy
but JJ takes down shuttle and race hill
on too easily the flank from guitar what
is happening rogue fall apart
Nora take the round race hill in side of
penthouse narrowly missing out on a kill
but will get that follow-up on to
eclipse and Mary Oh getting shuttle a
second for a film and suddenly Nora from
a 5 to 3 deficit put themselves in the
driver's seat but there's overtime in
front of us I know the crowd here loved
shouting it the phase versus market but
over time not really in a class dealio
with too fast gels this could be a good
concerted effort the maestro in and
marry you gets the down but doesn't
secure the kill easily is also down it's
all up to eclipse will we see it for the
first time but the piglia falls and
eclipse rotates he still has the wall
here and waiting for possible things as
rape goes for the diffuse around the
corner Barry who gets the kill and for
the first time in Rainbow six eSports
history we have an AIPAC team in the
semi-finals Nora Rango to one over road
taking the number 4 spot on our list is
cloud 9 Cinderella run to defy all odds
and conquer Dreamhack Montreal 2018 let
us paint you a picture cloud 9 were the
bottom feeders of the North American Pro
League repeatedly losing games oh 6 they
were so bad that it even became a meme
in the siege community taking few shots
in two Jarvis but there's no time left
and hot cold with a BM knife c9 the
second 600 like it's a good thing I have
twitch chat on because that's a scene
I've ever seen but by the time Dreamhack
Montreal came around a single roster
change completely transformed the team
cloud 9 came out on top in a tough group
beating out the likes of evil geniuses
and Lockett but that wasn't all they
cruised through the quarters semies and
eventually the finals - owing every team
in their path to lift the true
retro actually pushing through smoke
playing a splash like news I realized is
that the clock is about to hit 10
seconds here and there's few more
powerful positions to be and with a
shotgun there retros gonna go for one
he's gonna did it he's gonna go he
single-handedly saves the round
everybody from rogue lines up and that's
cloud nine taking four rounds no more
for this round in particular but here we
go
you mention the execute with slash but
there's their retro will great easily in
a 3v5 now shuttle lighting up lasting to
one - only one level but a smoke is
gonna go into possibly stop the push
here comes the toxic babes and caught us
we'll get a kill as retro gets one mark
gets traded off fox they get to kill
it's only one the miracle in Montreal is
cloud 9 defeating all expectations and
they have to work for it and they will
be your Dreamhack Montreal champion
number three in our list might look like
just a simple upset but it's actually
the cap off to one of the greatest
revenge stories in eSports history at
Dreamhack Montreal 2019 BTS had the odds
stacked against them not only were they
in the same group as g2 the best team in
the world but their star player Shaco
was playing his first LAN in two years
all because he'd been banned after g2
accused him of cheating I am the person
that got rifle Bend I protested him
that's me I didn't find this information
I made this information I'm the one that
got the evidence psychos tournament life
depended on winning a match against the
same man who got him banned so psycho
was out for vengeance
she's just to play a little bit more
safe three fires once again and
Schuykill finds him through the wall to
the hole that was made
Shaco is literally like the John wick of
siege man psycho finds another thief net
smoke dead goethe is all alone here
1 vs. 4 not even gonna find the first
one Shaco closes without shakers in a
great spot to find her never to kill
here
Oh Fabian is well a triple for Keiko
this is it unreal performance it's two
versus the world they don't have an inch
in this world I go find Southfork he's
looking for the ACE BDS is just powered
up no power up there max pizza they are
my friends mum power flawless
g2 and Pangu thought they had ended
psychos career but he came back and
ended g2 taking the runner-up spot on
our list is the most recent upset in
siege history that's right we're talking
about fanatics incredible victory over
team Empire at the 2020 siege
Invitational stuck in the group of death
against some of the world's greatest
teams nobody expected this fnatic to
make it out alive and after dropping
their opening match to tournament
favorites team Empire their fates looked
grim the one versus three but turns it
into a one versus two still got all the
work to do from selva needs a 4k if they
going to convert this round into
anything good for them tries to push
around the corner will not find the kill
an empire take a very convincing back
map and turn this series into two and 0
but after scraping by in the elimination
match fnatic got another shot at Empire
and they were out for revenge what
occurred is springing into action
opening pic for Empire to dad for it for
fnatic 3 looking for a 4th to people
watching commando in hand that's one for
joystick Evans he's still accurate 10 in
a row for fnatic my god what is
happening in this matchup fnatic are
keeping in pace with Empire magnet the
last one in sight and Dan finishes him
off text now and a 1v1 with Dan and he
will win the fight inside of cash as
mentalist heads downstairs virtue cast
of throws are down as well joystick
Falls it's only one left they said it
couldn't be done but it's Dan trenches
on in through the smoke 1 HP's got 3
kills to find fnatic will stun everybody
watching in utter disbelief Empire goes
out in groups and in a result that
nobody saw coming fnatic pulled it off
putting an end to the Russians
tournament run
taking the top spot on our list is the
upset to end all upsets it's fanatics
impossible victory over evil geniuses at
the season 8 / League finals now
eg were the undisputed number 2 team in
the world at this time and fnatic had
yet to achieve anything meaningful on an
international stage
oh yeah and fanatics captain he had a
medical emergency at the last minute so
they had to play with their coach dizzle
as a sub this is this is their time to
shine I I got to imagine though EG is
just gonna pull out all the stops to
make sure that it ends here honestly if
if eg lose to fnatic yeah I don't I
don't know if I'd even be able to cast
tomorrow which is my mind would be so
blown I don't think we'd be able to look
at me G the same way ever again
it was a classic matchup of David versus
Goliath and fnatic we're up to the task
young rotating in from the back as
disels already got one on nvk 2 v 2 as
lusty will get dropped all up to dizzle
now in the 1 V 2 he'll drop one will he
be able to do it neck rocks will spray
into dizzle he's trying to bait him in
the head far from Nick wraps around in a
magazine that disel collection we've to
do it right here right now
One Bowl will be more than enough yes
will go down aces let's court [ __ ] it
out in the yellow shots almost connected
to mesas he is back on that foot 12
again there we go one I don't wanna
fight risin aces with a double kill and
fnatic are closer and closer less man
alive as necrosis MV K's on the floor
it's looking like a double a back semis
done it they've done it phonetic
demolish eg fanatic came up victorious
in dramatic fashion toppling eg on the
back of some amazing plays from their
coach of all people and cemented
themselves in sieges history books well
there you have it the top ten upsets in
Rainbow six siege if you think we missed
one make sure to upset our list and let
us know in the comments and if you want
to see more great siege videos like this
one sub to the channel see you next time
eat alright or as net or as mild as
always in our [ __ ] off beaches nice
oh nice how does everyone know this is a
generic print from Ikea Jesus